okay
for people joining this live stream we
are exploring the question
of how to format uh data sets
and how to make themes for
presenting different kinds of
information in data sets
so the basic concept here
is to use themes like we do in plots
right
now just to remind me how
how plot themes work so plot themes are
specific to different kinds of plots
right
so if i do this and i say plot theme
right can somebody speak to this please
i mean in general the themes
are pretty universal across the plots
okay and what they do may differ but the
general set is the same
i mean there's a few special cases like
the one for
getting thick surfaces from the 3d plots
that are more
specific but okay so now here when we
look at plot theme
why isn't this mousing over correctly
something is wrong there
should be mousing over could you report
that as a ux problem
when i'm in the middle of this thing
mousing over here it should
for an option it should come up in some
way
yeah i don't understand why it doesn't
that's just wrong
um okay so for plot theme here
there are many specific types of
directives right
now presumably chris you've looked at
these for data sets presumably
yeah have you so do you have proposals
for what these analogous things like
full axis and so on should be for data
sets
no i thought that was what this meeting
was for is to decide what kinds of
things we need i see
all right okay so you don't you don't
have any proposals for this
so i mean i mean other than the the
ideas that i threw out in this example
notebook no
okay so so what we need first is
okay so here
let's see
okay so the so there are different
categories of thing here so the
is this a tim production basically the
stuff that's in here where did you where
did all this
go yeah yes it is at the top you got
eight base the base themes those we use
on everything okay and then everything
below that they're like feature themes
okay and those are like
function dependent you know depending
okay all right
fine yeah okay so then so then for
example things like thick lines
you know stuff like that we'll
definitely have on data sets
right because you can control that can't
you chris uh
there's not yet a frame option to
control frame styling no
okay all right so let's start making a
list here
of what we want um
let's see do i have a folder here yes i
do for data set
um
okay so what we're going to want
i think is so let's let's i mean what
are the elements of a data set
there's there's things like you know
there's background colors there's
um uh fonts
there's sizes of things
sizes of fonts sizes of cells
if i'm not mistaken yeah okay
there's
yes
okay there's also in terms of content
there's
illusion of content
and there's things about um
uh
alignment yes definitely alignment i
mean there's a lot of stuff that also
goes with um
um grid grids and so on
um but let me understand something else
i mean so what we're going to do for the
time being
we're probably going to have a data set
theme arrow
option is that the idea yeah
okay so this is
i mean eventually we're going to have a
general theme option
um okay all right fine so there's also a
basic
distinction between headers and content
i'm i'm wondering whether we should
imagine having a grid theme option
that well okay whatever sorry go ahead
you were saying something there's a
basic distinction between headers and
content
which often will be reflected in the
theme
i'm sorry styling for you know styling
the headers differently than the content
for example
or giving them different background i
mean that's a basic yeah yeah
right so i mean background colors for
content
and headers but there's also much more
elaborate things about alternating rows
and things like this alternating columns
different background colors for
different columns cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera but i mean what we're
trying to do here is we're trying to
make themes that are going to work
somewhat more generally
right okay so then does data
do any special formatting of
items like you know does it ever change
how a date object is displayed yep
yeah so so
content formatting is an issue there
okay
why don't you just do options of data
set to see all the options
well that's cheating no no i want to
let's not waste that time okay
okay
okay so header background is going to be
a color
right yeah
header display function what's that
you can you can intervene and tell it
how to format a header
so in other words you can say what the
content how the content should be
processed
right like framed of hash or something
okay
okay header size
that's just uh yeah that's like the item
size except for headers
i see an item size is then a maximum
it's got up twos and things like that in
it is that right
uh no it's uh
it's just numeric but it should have up
to
should allow up to right
right is up to used in that way i mean
there are there is a syntax i think
i'd have to look at grid there's a
syntax or i think you can give it
two items yes i'm not sure that up to
has been properly installed in item size
that should i don't i don't think it is
but that should be looked at okay so
let's let's take a look at a few other
things here so
sandra on our live stream is asking
about an image size type option for the
whole data set
do you understand the question yeah
um there isn't one currently uh and
but so so what it's doing is it's shrink
wrapping to the content
yeah correct does grid always do that or
does grid have a way of giving
an overall size that can then be
distributed down to the content
i don't believe it does you can just
specify individual okay
so i i do think that would be useful
because if you're making some documents
and you have multiple tables
it would be nice to have them all kind
of well i'm not sure if that would work
because maybe their headers won't align
and so on i mean
this is the same problem we have with
plots if you want to have multiple data
sets
let's think about that for a second here
right you've got multiple data sets
and they're different sized content but
you want the
rows and columns to agree
do you get what i'm saying yeah so an
optimal thing to do would be to be able
to take um
uh you know be able to interrogate a
data set and ask it
for its um kind of uh
design parameters so you can then feed
it to another data set
do you understand what i'm saying right
now you need to get you know hold of its
you know what the effective item size is
well you need to get absolute options
basically of the thing
do we have anything like that for
graphics where you can inherit
i mean because that would have been you
know in terms of
the the way that you're doing
multi-panel plots which i still find
really kind of unusable and i've never
used it um
the you know that's an alternative way
to think about multi-panel plots
is to be able to interrogate a plot for
its display parameters
and then feed that to another plot did
you understand what i'm saying
yeah do we have any way to do that um
i mean right now it's done internally
as i mean that's what like graphics grid
does
is it looks at what the image padding is
and that sort of thing okay so fine
one of the things we might consider
doing maybe we could write a function
repository item to do it to begin with
is something that interrogates a plot
and feeds it to another plot
in other words it's a basically the
concept is something like
just like we have conform audio and so
on it'd be a conform
graphics type thing right
maybe maybe that's a good functional
repository thing to begin with
um okay but let's let's go back here
uh okay data split display panel what is
that
um that tells you the the initial drill
down
point what does that mean
if if you click a header it drills down
to that header
and you can but you can specify a path
your data set display panel which gives
you the initial path
as if you had clicked on a header i see
so that's the initial state
yeah i don't think that's the kind of
thing that we should have and i
that doesn't seem like the right kind of
thing to have in the theme
no i agree i i you know i
don't even think it should be documented
it was that programmatically may be
useful in cases
yes but again again it's an inheritance
thing like like i've got this data set
in this state
i want to keep it in that state i want
to i can also imagine somebody animating
through that
right would that work and animate i
don't see why not
well try it to be a good demo to animate
through showing different pieces of a
data set
um how is it specified the right hand
side
it's just the path i mean if you hover
over a data set header you'll see the
path annotation underneath it
that's the argument you give i'm not
seeing that a
header but i was looking at content here
why doesn't this work is this a bitmap
no um
right
by the way in a data set for
a let me show you something if i go
um something like
uh
oops why is this not typing help why did
that select there
that was totally wrong
did you stay reported
oh boy too many values okay here we go
okay so now i click this what am i
seeing there in the footer
that's not really the name of that row
is it
that is that's the path um to that thing
really yeah so how do i get that path um
right click on that header copy position
so you're telling me if i type that in
no it's not the path that's the path
what are you showing down there
probably the common name well it yeah
it's the
but it isn't the path you told me it was
the path it's not the path
well it's it's the path
using the common using data sets
formatting for things
in a special formatting for
editing things it's pretty confusing
i mean i wonder what we can do
maybe we need something on hover here
hey do we have noah here he might have
opinions about this
maybe we need something on hover that is
a way
to i mean i i do not like right-click
stuff it's not very discoverable
i mean i suppose when you hover over the
item you could have like a small
sort of drop down arrow that appears i
don't see why not it doesn't seem
harmful because i mean
it's like you're just reading this data
if you're reading the data set
that's what i would suggest that we
expose the copy
more obviously there am i making sense i
don't think we have the technology to
support
a a hover menu that you can choose from
if that's what you're suggesting
well i'd i'd be happy to begin with just
a copy
okay we can talk about a hover menu but
let's that we could feed that idea into
the
front end team but for the time being we
could just have a hop
essentially a click to copy could it not
be done with an attached cell
because you could just sort of put
whatever you wanted in it then
in the local can we attach a cell on
hover or does it have to be a click no
uh good question i'm not sure
okay no no i didn't i meant the little
arrow the little arrow that appears that
is on hover if you click on that
oh i see yeah
okay we've got a couple of comments on
our live stream that are interesting one
is
asking for angled labels
here do we have any any way of doing
that
what what's meant by angled tip
oh i see rotated yeah i'm sure you can
give an item display function
and rotate it um there's probably though
there's a bug where it doesn't properly
account for the change
size if the size okay let's try it
anyway
so in this case here we would say what
um header display function arrow
arrow what rotate
45 degrees yeah
i'll be so happy when we have this
hovering mechanism to let me
automatically add that
parenthesis whatever thing ta-da
nice well okay is there a way to do it
for only the
column headers yeah how do i do that um
wrap a list around that right hand side
make the first element automatic
ta-da nice now how what if i wanted to
do it down
another level here add another automatic
that's actually down two levels there
two automatics no but i want to do it
well okay but fine
but this is useful and this is something
that we should have that is one of the
kind of
stories down here um
so uh
okay so one of the items let's see where
is it
um original concert wait a minute oh
content and headers wait a minute
how display com well okay so this is
this is
um uh features right
so a feature probably wants to be uh
rotated column labels
i don't know whether that's the right
name for it but that's the concept
makes sense that's just a feature that
you might have or not have
um and i i think then we want to say i
mean
with both rotated column labels and
there's vertical column labels
oops i think with our current technology
vertical's the only interesting case
i don't know about that um
i mean because you know so normally when
you do rotate it like a 45 degree angle
i think
then you know
that you know when it goes off at the
angle it's allowed to sort of cross over
into the next column okay whatever
whatever whatever whatever well
that's a that's the detail about this
let's not get into that
okay ethan on our live stream is saying
forget data set themes do notebook
themes
i thought that's what we had style
sheets for
and how does this respond to the style
sheet
um themes there's a mechanism in plot
themes to use
styles from the style sheet
yeah so if i go to dark mode the the um
tim maybe you can speak to that i mean
if i go to dark mode will my plots
um correctly uh adapt
i mean a better a clearer example is if
you were to have like a wolfram alpha
notebook edition
notebook but i want to know the answer
that question
if i go to dark mode do my plots adapt
i don't think for dark mode that wasn't
one of the original
style sheets well but that's not what
i'm asking i mean i'm asking if
if it picks things up from a style sheet
it should work when a new style sheet is
added right
i mean so there are some things like
you know tick labels and access
style and whatnot that you know it will
pick
up from the style sheet
um but there's also cases where
at the time that it generates the plot
it knows
what the st what the notebook style
sheet is
and may choose say different line colors
for the main i understand but then it's
it's cooked it's goose at that point
right
at that point it's cooked right um
okay but that's okay i mean that's still
that's still
fine and useful um
okay there's a question here okay with
data set
you have a data set with certain plots
as values
would a plot theme argument to data set
affect plots as well interesting
presumably not because the plot's going
to be generated before
[Music]
data set has its own formatting for
plots you'd have to intervene with an
uh item display function but right but
so then maybe there's a plot theme
maybe there are options like plot theme
that should be possible for the data set
as a whole that could auto intervene if
you understand what i'm saying
in other words options that get passed
down
i mean i think that is a reasonable
possibility
pass down wouldn't it just
that would be like plot option zero plot
theme something
i mean but data set doesn't hold its
arguments
well so what's what so what is chris
talking about about the reformatting of
graphics
he's talking about that the graphics
object you've got the graphics object
right
maybe it isn't a plot theme but you've
got the graphics object
okay so maybe maybe that's wrong but you
need to have
various kinds of theme level options for
what to do
that are analogous to plot theme for
what to do at the graphics level with
the graphics
am i making sense i mean i think there
probably are some
you know things that can be done like
i'm guessing chris means that he's
setting
image size of either explicitly or
anything hey listen
we've got limited time here so let's um
um
the uh
okay so
we all agree that fonts background etc
um i do think that the styles that we
have
um you know business detailed marketing
minimal monochrome
let's let's try and see whether we can
channel those styles for data set
those themes rather for data set you see
what i'm saying
yeah i don't think they're silly to try
to try to emulate
i mean i'm not sure what else they seem
like reasonably good distinctions to me
you know the i'm in favor of that of
having you know that standard set and
then
you know the feature themes you know the
more specific features you know
some theme things that they you know
that follow that
are going to so roughly what we're going
to be doing in you know like in business
for example
it's probably brighter colors less
detail
um uh you know maybe bolder i don't know
i mean whatever tim has done
for plots probably makes sense here as
well
and we added dark mode i mean dark mode
isn't part of common but marketing
kind of looks dark mode but it's really
not the intent of marketing
i feel like we should have a proper just
dark mode
that is that is default yeah that's
default dark mode
default styling but dark mode yeah
exactly
which is the analogy to classic
but it's dark mode right yeah that makes
sense to me
tim does that make sense to you uh yes
it is
okay all right so let's let's go now
what we're now
going to be mostly talking about then
given that overall picture
we're talking about so for example let's
talk about some of the featuroids
that we could imagine here so let's say
here we would say alternating
row colors is probably a featureoid
right right
um which you know is relevant for some
things and not for others
um
okay now i mean also probably
alternating column colors
is that okay
all right and and that presumably needs
to be done if we have a hierarchical
thing
we'll have to pick different colors as
we go down
does that make sense to people like i
think actually
reasonable for the top level go ahead um
the option or the name would probably
just be alternating
colors because i mean you can specify a
theme for a given level of a data set
and you don't know a priori if it's rows
or columns
it'll just be alternating color theme
no but but well okay but i mean um
and but you you're going to want to be
able to set it at the top level
right yeah i don't know whether this is
i think you want row and column of
separate themes
no you don't know if it's you don't
necessarily know if it's row or column
so you know you specify you specify this
for the third level of the data i don't
care
look look look i i get what you're
saying chris the fact is
that if somebody knows that they have a
grid you know i think it's useful to be
able to say alternating column colors
if you don't have columns if you have a
data set that only has rows nothing
alternates in that case
i see what you're saying okay
um ethan is suggesting a sub option for
dark
mode versions of each of our um things i
i'm not
sure how necessary that is because i
think some of them we definitely don't
want dark mode like scientific we do not
want dark mode for that
that's for people putting things in
scientific papers when i see a dark mode
scientific paper we'll get interest in
dark mode for scientific
um the
okay so let's let's go down and look
okay so that's one type of thing
um another thing which we're not seeing
here but i assume it's possible
is different colors for different levels
of header sure
and i think that should probably be i
don't know whether that should be the
default so let's let's say
um uh
let's see varying header colors
i don't know that's not a very good name
but but um
uh different header
well no no it's not really colors header
backgrounds
bearing header backgrounds
actually this should also be backgrounds
here
right because that's what it is row
colors will be the actual color
of the content right right
which is another thing we might want
okay
now okay so alternating is one thing
and i mean you know you could get very
cutesy and have alternating not in
not in not on off on off but i don't
think we care about that i don't think
that needs to be a feature that we
specify
at in this kind of bank switch feature
specification
um so
uh i don't know whether varying is not
the right term
but what would be the right term for
that um
i mean and just till we're clear there
is there are
these headers there are these headers i
don't know whether we want to
distinguish those colors
and there are definitely these headers
here do you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah
so what's the i mean there could be a
colored
is that something one wants a color for
the row header is a column for the color
column headers that are different you
can try it out
header background arrow a list of colors
that's quite nice
that's quite nice
i like that idea to have to have
basically
something which goes through a color map
jeremy tim
etc going through a color map as you go
down levels
now now these content areas they're also
at different levels right
yeah you do the same thing with
uh just background
okay i think it's going to get too weird
with that i don't know designers
comments about this i think there's a
case for this it
what what happened to the color with
mass and radius there it looks like it
injected it
oh it didn't it didn't have just the
gray okay fine
is there something that cycles or yeah
well i mean it wouldn't be a cycle it's
a drill down we're going deeper deeper
deeper
deeper yeah but you can make you can
make a cyclic
if you just give a like but light orange
and light green and a list
no i understand and i'm not sure it
should be cyclic i mean that's the
question of whether it's
um you know cyclic cyclic
or or continuing to be different
i think continuing to be different i
think this is a this is
a case where it's just like you don't
even know that it's a deeper thing
unless you get what i'm saying i don't
know how we indicate depth i mean it's
it's similar to the problem when we're
you know if we were coloring parentheses
in an expression
we've never succeeded in figuring out a
good way to do that but here at least
visually you can maybe connect things
i'm not sure whether there's a
logic to how the colors go as you drill
further down
if i'm making sense and whether it's
just random colors or whether there's
some
i think it can just be random colors
because by the time you're at seven
levels of
drilling that's a very exotic situation
in in plot themes there is some way of
effectively making that parametric right
i mean you you
presumably want to specify not only
varying colors but
what the color set is sure that's just a
color data
object right but but you but there
what's the syntax for getting that into
a plot theme
it's one of the method options
yeah i don't think i mean plot themes
are preset and that's what we're trying
to do here as well
you know they're not but if you if you
want user modifiable stuff
use the underlying options
you know start the idea is start from
the plot theme and then you can
overwrite it with specific options and
that's the way to do this
right we're not trying to give people
you know infinite control there
if they want infinite control use the
actual roar right right but
am i wrong about that are there no
effectively parametric plot themes
i believe there are not what's that i
don't know there are some parametric
plot themes
well yeah background is one of them but
it's not documented
colorful you know it is there okay yeah
okay so you can give the explicit
background color
but these are ones where you are
specifying a color scheme
right for the plot and this is a limited
number of colors
schemes and we should have the same type
of thing for data set
whether it's the exact same color
choices it'd be nice if it was
but i don't know if it will make sense
right i mean like bold color for you
well okay let's skip bold color but like
cool color would probably be
you know maybe more pastel versions of
those
right i think this makes sense to try
okay yeah this is sensible
this labels thing that's perfectly
sensible here
um this is interesting this is
this is um i mean clearly you can change
the grid lines here right
um there's not yet an option for
changing the grid lines
okay all right but then for the future
it's like
grid lines you know
and then that's that's things like
dotted
etc etc etc dotted colors
et cetera so you can't even change the
colors of the grid lines yet no
okay
okay so now there are things like
um are you in a position i mean like
like the overall
border how do you how is that specified
you mean that outer frame outer border
that's what i'm asking
it's just it's fixed okay
so we might want an appearance option in
general for that
if we know what else we're we're
allowing
that making sense because some of these
things like dark mode will clearly not
work unless we have some way to reset
that
go ahead i was just i'd be apprehensive
about playing with the actual
ux elements too much you sort of want
them to be
roughly consistent i guess um okay
that's a reasonable claim i mean the
only problem is if you're if you're
trying to print this in a paper
and it's got all kinds of you know
interactive ux
crowd around it that's probably the
wrong thing
right so i mean there's a case and i
don't know what this does when you print
it
but when you export it but i think there
are definitely cases i mean
we probably want um
you know borderless or something
for printing does that make sense to
people yeah
yeah and do we have an option that will
you know sort of turn off the illusion
so you just see the big full table all
at once
um yes it's not yet in this version but
i'm working on that
well i mean now you can do it now using
max items
there's no religious case i mean the ie
iec full table
um right which is just max items
infinity right noah you were going to
say something
uh well i mean if you're actually
printing it out
do you need the outer
no you don't that's my point but i mean
i think you might want to see
in the actual printing you shouldn't do
it by default
but i'm saying that you might want a
style here
where it is as if printed so to speak
oh okay i'm with you yeah yeah that
makes sense
um okay so let's look
at some of the more elaborate issues of
um
uh so go ahead one thing that's not on
your list
is interactive behaviors like for
example tool tips
is that something that you would want to
put in a theme sure
what are the interactive behaviors one
might have well you can you can do
anything i mean you can you can give an
item display function that wraps it with
tooltip or annotation or whatever well
so the thing that one might imagine
is right now that's just telling me the
position here
um the uh
um is there anything else we could
usefully have in that in that tool tip i
don't know by default
wait what do you call are you calling
the annotation underneath the tooltip
i'm calling the translation underneath
it well it's the path right
but i was talking about actual tooltips
as you when you hover over an item
that's what i'm looking at yeah i'm
talking about a tooltip that would show
up
near the item right as opposed in the
footer right
but the question is is there's something
generically useful there the only thing
generically useful that i can imagine
is something about the input form
well for example you could imagine like
magnified if you have a very small
condensed table you would want to make a
tooltip that magnifies
well actually i can see something which
if it's a lighted
the tooltip by default should show you
the full thing
that seems like a good feature in
general um
could right why not
or at least shows you a bigger piece of
the thing yeah
okay so this is tool tip to show
magnified form of a lighted data
there's also tool tip
to show bigger versions of graphics
which might also be a useful thing
almost in general
okay we've got um
uh comments from ben here is not a fan
of
how the column scroll bar is implemented
with a data set that has lots of columns
it's a pain to have to scroll the page
to see content only to realize you have
to scroll back
to adjust the column score bar to show
what is that about that sounds like a ux
bug by the way did we um
okay
okay that i mean that that
did do chris do you understand what no i
don't are you scrolling back for what
reason
okay let's make a data set with a bunch
of um columns okay
so how do we do that we just say table
we just say like yeah it's kind of
it's it's not easy to do because it'll
for for easy data sets it'll just align
the column the wide columns what do you
mean
um well go ahead and try one i mean if
you just give like a big
identity matrix okay it'll it'll align
each
each row will be an illusion of columns
that's useless how do i show that full
how do i show that without illusion that
must be an option to show it without a
limit yeah yeah
give get some data set max items
arrow infinity
oh come on that didn't do it why didn't
that work
well that's another thing that i'm
working on because because some
decisions are made
it's effectively too early okay so i
can't undo them
i mean that's the code that i inherited
okay
all right so this is so wait a minute
what happened here
that's not 40 columns how do i how do i
scroll
it it is a multi-column display it
wrapped it for you
oh i see okay but so is there a
horizontal scroll bar
yes there is um i'm trying to think of a
you know there's there's no example data
set or anything there's no
no easy way to get at it you need a data
set
with homogeneous content that's very
wide
scroll bar is hard to use hard to see
and not smooth
well we're talking about this uh skull
bar here
it's weird that as you as you move the
skull bar
the height changes
right uh well it more or less has to
work that way
otherwise you'd have to have partial
columns
it you have a partial rows right i mean
it's because the row heights are
different
it's scrolling because it's different
yeah i understand it's scrolling by rows
it's not scrolling by content size
okay um
and and i mean the is that the right
thing in in
why does this not extend to the bottom
here
because the data set doesn't know what
size it is it's estimating the size okay
so what happened here i just clicked
that that's obviously a bug
right if i click that's been fixed
okay i click the down arrow i better be
able to click on that down arrow at the
same you know
continue to click on that down arrow do
we want it to be the case that as you
scroll as you hover on the toolbar
i mean on on the scroll bar that the
scroll bar becomes darker in color
seems like a good thing so that you're
highlighting it
right so you know you're going to do
something with it so it's not like it's
a dead animal
type thing see what i'm saying yeah
i think that would be a good idea from a
ux point of view
right so as you as you hover over it it
darkens to indicate that it's active and
then you can scroll with it
is that is that uh cursor
the double arrow cursor is that i mean
it's definitely not what i would expect
to see here right here i just see
a an arrow cursor
right yeah
um so that seems like it's a wrong
cursor
right and it would be better to just
highlight
as you hover over the toolbar over the
scroll bar
so
okay
um let's see i think that that should be
a very good idea it would really help
understand what's going on there i also
wonder whether
in this footer comments from jeremy or
noah
or somebody about this i mean should
this footer light up before you actually
hit this
hit the specific item within the footer
i think the fact that the buttons
themselves change when you hover over
them is
sort of sufficiently obvious to know all
right okay so here's another question
what about
tool tips but maybe that's just me
yes tooltips will be nice another thing
is if i
go to this row why not highlight the
whole row
why is this thing dead as a stone i mean
why not if i bother to put my mouse here
why not
highlight the things in that row
do you understand what i'm saying chris
yeah
um is there an action to take in that
case
or no action i don't think it needs to
have an action i think it's just well i
mean there's an action which is that you
click
to what why isn't that clicking down you
understand
why isn't that highlighted there's
nothing to click down to
um
my concern would be i mean it would take
a lot of machinery to highlight
a row and that's likely to bog
down i mean these are that's you're
giving an implementation excuse that's
not what i was interested in
okay so what we're interested in is what
the design should be
we worry later about whether it's
implementable but your twice it's it's
that that hover effects to me indicates
a click event is going to happen
right i mean it's hard to hover without
a click event attached to it well
why do you want it to highlight so you
can follow the row yeah so i can follow
the row
yeah sandra is pointing out that in
spreadsheets you typically click the
header and it highlights the column
but that's also because you can then
delete the column right there's
um all right so that's a separate thing
we should discuss separately
is is what those hover effects and so on
but i want to get to some other things
here
um
okay
let's talk about all of these kind of
um displaying uh content
okay so this is a a type of issue which
is
um uh content um
the uh
um content based
uh styling okay that's a
topic whoops i i need to format that
differently here but that's that's the
thing we need to talk about
right you understand what i mean like
like this here yeah
okay so um and those are probably
features
that we want to have but how do you
specify something like this that is
you're specifying
oh wow how does it auto-scale this
oh it's not autistic i think that syntax
entirely wrong
what's that i think that syntax is wrong
what syntax background goes to function
and the one below it that has like item
style goes to function
why what should it be
uh i i'm not sure but
i mean like you know as steven says you
know you happen to pick data that is
between zero and one
right i mean there's a color function
scaling type issue right so this is like
a color function
and then there's usually a color
function scaling option which determines
whether it will auto scale for the range
of the data
or whether it's absolute right and also
you know it's the case that like if you
were to copy out that pure function the
hue
you know through ampersand and replace
it by foo where you say
foo of a underscore equals u of a
then it doesn't behave the same why not
why doesn't it behave the same i mean
presumably because it's looking to see
if it has head function
like whether to you know try to generate
colors or to use the thing
directly as a color that's something
that's a that's a metaphor that we've
used many other times
of you know value versus uh function
so i'm not concerned about that i'm more
concerned about how do you deal with the
scaling issue
how do you deal if i wanted to auto
scale this for the range right in this
case i want to get the hue to not wrap
around
but to have to be scaled down to the
overall value to the overall maximum
value how would i do that
there's no good way to do it i mean
other than calculating that beforehand
okay so that's exactly what color
function scaling is about
i mean in in okay so what other things
can you
so can you change the uh
the the color of the borders around a
particular cell so for example
if i have a cell which is negative can i
make its borders be a different color
okay so you should be able to do that
so what we've got is something where
we've got we've got several different
things here
right speaking of negative values is
probably one of those themes based on
you know in your content-based styling
what do you say yeah right right
highlight negative values
yeah with a red font for example
right and different different things
would be okay
um should there be something like
accounting theme
i don't know probably not i mean uh
all right don't they have standard ways
you know putting things in parentheses
or
whatever yeah but that's that's what we
do we have an accounting form you mean
i mean the accounting type theme isn't
i'm scheduled to go back to that
but i do think that um
okay so okay
we got a couple of issues here so first
point is
what can be styled
right so it's the it's the actual
content
eg font it's the
background color and it's the border
well an uh border the the
the actual border or an
inner border so i'm saying
let's say i wanted to put you know i
wanted to highlight
particular elements here right now i
might want to do that by having an inner
frame here
i think that's more sensible than having
the actual border
be highlighted because the actual border
will you know have contention with the
neighboring cells and so on
um ben is saying he can send his
example data set that causes trouble to
us and that would be great
um the uh okay
so so okay so let's just inventory what
kinds of things we might want to do here
so there's there's i mean
uh highlight negative values there's
heat map
there's some kind of heat map value i
don't know
heat map i don't know how we say it but
but basically heat map
um
this is weird it's amusing it's trying
to make a monochrome heat map but you
got to do something with the font to
make it readable
fair enough well okay so that would be
what heatmap would do
if you went to monochrome overall theme
if you were in monochrome overall theme
yeah okay now this is interesting this
is something where
you actually don't have the values right
where the the actual display is not even
of the value itself
making sense right
is that really something that we want to
support directly
or is that something that people i mean
you see that occasionally
where it's you know it's usually done
you know for a particular column or
something
well the other point is you can have the
actual value in there
and you can have the background be you
know
you can say something like um
yeah and by the way these things like
highlight negative values and things you
might indeed want that for a particular
column
right which which the syntax allows you
to do
okay so what you're proposing is that
that we'd be able to mix
these theme specifications with the
existing syntax right
yep
um so you can have several themes
applying to different parts of the data
set
yeah i think that's reasonable that's
good so long as the syntax
plays nice which i don't immediately
know
did you know what i'm saying because
this is going to be you know strings
lists of strings all that kind of thing
that means that we can't have
a list here meaning something other than
the kind of level drill down that it
means in the case of the overall syntax
and in general if there's list ambiguity
the the outer level of list
is interpreted as the value not as a
list of values
that's the way alignment works that's
the way item size works okay but so here
we can imagine something where the
background is is one of these and where
the actual value is in there i mean the
the you know we can still have the value
even though there's a
um you know you can say you could you
could put the value in there it could be
in a tool tip
all right so we could call that value
bar or something
value bars not sure if that's the right
name but something like that
um and uh
you know again i don't even know whether
it's horizontal or vertical but
presumably most of the time horizontal
um um
let's see i put it i could do this in
chat
okay it's more
i'm going to say graphics
graphic only values in other words
i.e
just make make all the numbers etc
into something graphical i don't know if
that's a good idea
but that's a possible overall theme idea
um
let's see so the question from honor
here can we auto scale rows columns of
tables relative to header values
oh i see well i mean
you're asking yeah right right i think
that's an ornate
possibility that these these
relative values here the the the
question is is that this is the analog
of color function scaling for these bars
right in other words if a bar is such
and such a number of pixels wide
does it mean the same number in this
column as it does in this column
i think that's ornate amusing and and
certainly
specifiable programmatically but i don't
think that's a that's a default kind of
thing to worry about
probably it's column relative so that's
another
that's another thing is is you know
um make i mean this bad name but make
column iconography
agree
i.e eg
eg scale colors
are the same etc because not obvious you
want to do that if you have a color
function scaling thing
it could be by column or by row or by
alt or by whole table
see what i'm saying yeah
i mean i think
you know there's things that we're
missing that are you know sort of
more common and obvious when we're down
in the weeds
so for example you know all columns the
same width
or allow them to float same for the rows
heights
yes okay okay okay okay okay so that
that's a good point
right so what we're saying is here
um you know
equal width
columns
equal height rows
that's a good point and then you have
things like how do i want to format
dates
you know how many digits do i want to
show on numbers
okay am i using scientific form or
blowing everything out to
well that's right right so there's
there's an issue there
about um
okay well this is okay hold on so
we're not organizing this very well but
detailed content formatting
we've got issues like number precision
we've got issues like scientific
notation
um with dates i'm not sure you know okay
so date formatting yeah i guess that's
right
there are there are different date
formatting options that you might choose
um
let's see sander is pointing out
could there be a highlighting method in
other words when you
but the question is how if if you
highlight
how do you highlight things
does she mean highlighting on hover or
highlighting when to make like
select a sub wrecked
no i think the oh that's an interesting
question no no no
i mean highlighting just generally if
you were to put something if you put a
generic wrapper just like we have
highlight graph
if there was a generic wrapper that
indicated highlight
these elements in the source here
i mean there's a question of if if we
could have a generic item for
highlighting
what would it um uh
you know what would that be like i don't
know whether we want that
i mean that's a question generic
highlighting mechanism
okay all right we are running out of
time here
but i want to um i mean and this is
certainly not our last meeting we're
just getting started on this topic
um maybe we can pull together these
various things we've talked about here
um i mean i think that the uh
in terms of content um
oh yeah
um yeah there's there's okay so there's
uh
hands on our live stream is pointing out
about alignment
and um yeah i mean there's alignment
on decimal points etc are various
different
alignment options um
i i really do think in this case here
like the number precision is an
important issue
because that's 0.20 is quite possibly
what we want to use there
um uh someone was pointing out here that
that
um you know whatever we do here should
be
also doable in in um
uh you know that grid should support
these things and yes that is a future
i mean i don't know i don't know in
terms of of what you're doing right now
chris when you add
functionality here to the formatting of
of um data set
is that getting back ported to grid or
not no
no okay so that's a separate thing that
has to be done
okay and also table view is another
place where we should think about which
of these things can be carried over
all right well what is that now so that
is a hover that highlights
because when i click it it goes to that
right right
but that is not clickable it is
clickable
it wasn't clickable i go to moons
i hit the moon you're already at moons
yeah well right so that's not okay fine
um okay another thing that should be
parameterizable is how this
works how how is the illusion of these
things working
i mean okay so so i think that's true
right so there's a general thing here
which which we had
um why did we have this we had something
here that said
no illusion i seat full table so what we
want to do
is um we want to have something which
says
uh high elision or lower lesion
highlighting of of of high illusion
lower legion
or something that's something that
controls yeah
sort of the density of the illusions or
something
boy that's that's an a bug in look at
that there's a smart quote bug
somebody should note that please you got
it
um you know how aggressively
are sub
tables alighted
okay um
all right okay ethan is suggesting us
see more and see
less we
i mean that's kind of what we have in
the
oh i see what you're saying so you're
saying if we go here
wait a minute why am i not seeing oh i
see if i have a longer table
right if i go um
uh um yeah just like we have in large
output
right there's there's a generic that
would be an attached cell
type thing about well
okay so see more see less why do we have
a table that is big enough here here we
go here we go
so this is showing i see so the idea
would be a ux element down here
that simply says that such a good idea
that's a good idea rather than paging
this
just expand it that's a good idea you
can you can right click the rows and
there's a menu that gives you that
i would never have known well
brilliant but undiscoverable utterly
undiscoverable
that's nice but give me a give me a way
to to
you know give me an icon that pulls that
up
makes sense
[Music]
um
maybe a plus sign i don't know more
i don't know so i we don't want to see
the words show
more every time we see a table but some
kind of icon there would make sense to
me
maybe an expander some kind of visual
expander icon
make sense
jeremy or somebody do you well that
makes sense if that's the only
functionality i mean it could be a
general purpose
icon if there's other things we need to
add to the menu
um
okay yes well okay so it could be a gear
or it could be a simply expander and
contractor
here right where those potentially give
you
once you know that there's expand and
contract um
i mean honestly once you have an
expander icon underneath it could be
a contracting um
uh
uh thing all right i think we have to
wrap here because i've got to go to
something else
um i would uh this is a good start
um so one scheduling issue i'm leaving
for pto at the end of the week and i'll
be back in the end of september
well we need to have some other meeting
then so somebody's got to fit it in
um
okay uh by the way there's a for people
on the live stream you might be
interested at 4 pm eastern today there
is another design review
of something utterly different topic
biosequences
uh molecules that
represent uh well yes
things like dna um okay
different different topic um all right
okay so you um
uh somebody sent me that notebook
yeah who's gonna do that yeah i can i
can send it to you chris
okay all right good stuff all right
thanks to everybody here thanks to
the live stream